We are taking your calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47
50, and there are so many folks interested
in getting on.
Let's go to our caller from the 4 1 4 area
code who's calling today from 4 1 4.
Hi, David.
Hi, who's this is?
And this is a pie paying.
And I have a question about kind of what you've
been saying for months about the only way
to get Trump out is by voting impeachment
not being the way to go.
25TH Amendment not being the way to go.
And seen Tromsø increasein incompetence in
just today's news, with Trump reengaging with
conflict in Iran.
This obviously being an incredibly dangerous
situation.
Yes, especially layered on top of the Corona
virus.
This is coupled with the voter suppression
being in Wisconsin, you we had that whole
battle with.
You know, our election is still going on in
the midst of a pandemic, voter suppression,
etc..
It seems like the call for the only way to
get him out is by voting is becoming a weaker
and weaker argument because Republicans keep
attacking that avenue to get him out.
Do you have anything to say to that argument?
Of course.
And my argument is not that Trump is not worthy
of impeachment and removal, but with a Republican
Senate.
It will not happen.
I'm not saying Donald Trump is not worthy
of removal under the 25th Amendment, but he
is his own cabinet is not going to move to
remove Donald Trump.
So when I say the only way of getting him
out is voting him out, I'm not pretending
that the election will necessarily be fair.
And I'm not pretending that impeachment and
the 25th Amendment would be incorrect strategies.
I'm merely saying the only chance we actually
have is to vote him out in November.
And so they're going to be purging the voter
rolls.
They've already been doing it.
They're going to be limiting early voting.
They're going to try to push for in-person
voting, even if it's dangerous because of
the pandemic, which is disproportionately
likely to keep Democratic voters at home.
We need to knowing that blobby every state
to go to vote by mail.
At least the states that will matter here
in Massachusetts.
There's already Rotary or 40 mayors that have
written to the governor saying we have the
system.
We have absentee ballots.
Let's expand it.
Now, Massachusetts won't make a difference
in the election.
If Wisconsin and Michigan and these other
states do it.
So we need to knowing that it's our only shot,
knowing they won't play fair.
We need to get moving now to ensure that we're
actually positioned to remove him in November.
Well, I agree with that.
So you're saying that our efforts should be
in things like reaching out to lawmakers to
say, let's get to vote by mail thing rolling.
Yes.
That's what you can have, at least a fair
shot.
That's right.
And we've got to highlight every opportunity
we have to fight the voter roll purges as
well.
Exactly.
Well, I appreciate your time, I appreciate
you exactly this because this is not a concern
of mine.
I feel I've been feeling more and more frustrated
with your increasing call for, you know, vote
a vote.
Is the only way to get out, come out and fight.
Well, they keep attacking that avenue, but
at least you know it.
I feel a little bit of hope.
There's something we can do about that.
Right.
For example, when Wisconsin had their primary,
you know, I would send you an email.
Let me enjoy it.
11TH hour email blast, too.
I mean, it was the health secretary to, you
know, put in some emergency measure.
I mean, it was going out on a limb entirely,
but it just I felt like I could do something.
So hopefully now that we have a lot more time,
we can try to mitigate this kind of, you know,
this attempted, you know, completely squashing
democracy.
Yes.
And we've got to get active on it now, which
is why it's so important and that you are
talking about it.
Thank you so much for the call.
I really do appreciate hearing from you.